[Music]
what advice would you have for someone
wanting to break into machine learning
it's a great time to break in I I think
there's just no doubt at all that we're
still in the early stages of seeing the
impact of this new approach where
effectively software computer science is
being reinvented there are just lots of
opportunities for more automation making
more use of interpretation of human
language material for me or in other
areas like vision and Robotics so you
want to get some kind of good foundation
right so knowing some of the core
technical methods of machine learning
understanding ideas of how to build
models and data diagnose errors all of
these core things beyond that I think
it's also useful to learn something
about human language and the nature of
the problems that involves I mean even
though people aren't directly I'm going
to be encoding rules of human language
into their Computing system a
sensitivity is a sort of what kind of
things happen in language and what to
look out for and what you might want to
model
um that's still a useful skill to have